Taiwán se ha convertido en algo así como
la reproducción asiática de la irreductible
aldea de Asterix y Obelix.
Un pequeño enclave rodeado de un gran imperio
que se lo quiere comer...
Y tal y como ocurre con la pequeña aldea
gala, los ciudadanos de Taiwán también tienen
su particular pócima mágica para defenderse
de sus enemigos….
Claro que en este caso no está preparada
por ningún Druida... hablamos de los Estados
Unidos, de la fuerza de los Estados Unidos.
Bueno… de los Estados Unidos... y también,
recientemente, de algo más.
Amigos, Taiwan tiene un nuevo aliado, un nuevo
secreto que ya está alimentado la ira de
Pekín. Atentos.
(EL ENFADO DE PEKÍN)
Amigos, Taiwán,está haciendo frente a una
enorme presión por parte de de la China continental,
que, tal y como sabéis, reclama la isla como
parte de su territorio.
Y, ojo, que no hablamos de un juego ni del
típico tira y afloja tan típico de la política
internacional... [Me la devuelves, me la quitas,
me enfado, te amenazo, venga lo dejamos estar.]
Para nada...
En este caso Pekín ha fijado incluso fecha
de caducidad:
(Veréis, el gobierno chino ha dejado claro,
una y otra vez, que está dispuesto a todo
y que antes del año 2049 - el año del centenario
de la República Popular China - Taiwan deberá
reincorporarse a la China continental.
Claro que... con todo esto hay un problema...
y no precisamente pequeño: los taiwaneses
no están por la labor, no quieren saber nada
de todo esto.)
De hecho, os lo hemos contado aquí en VisualPolitik,
en 2016 el Partido Progresista Democrático
de Tsai Ing-Wen [Una de nuestras premiadas
en 2017, por cierto] que se inclina por las
tesis independentistas se hizo con el poder,
con todo el poder.. tanto con el congreso
como con la presidencia.
Y desde entonces... digamos que Pekín no
se lo ha tomado nada pero que nada bien.
Bueno, qué diantres... se lo ha tomado fatal.
(Desde que Tsa Ing-Wen se convirtió en Presidenta...desde
prácticamente el primero minuto, las presiones
de Pekín contra la isla se multiplicaron...
y ya en los últimos meses están alcanzando
niveles de auténtica obsesión política.
Ha cortado lazos diplomáticos, ha tratado
de castigar económicamente a Taiwán y ha
puesto en marchas enormes ejercicios militares
en torno a la isla.)
Pero ahí no queda todo.
Además, el gobierno de Xi Jinping está utilizando
todos los medios a su alcance para borrar
del mapa el nombre y la identidad de Taiwán.
Por ejemplo, cuando publicamos nuestro primer
vídeo sobre Taiwán... eran 20 los países
que reconocían formalmente a la isla como
China, como la China legítima.
[Sí, como ya os contamos, Taiwan nunca ha
declarado su independencia... sino que durante
años se ha reivindicado como el gobierno
legítimo de China. Y claro, diplomáticamente,
un país solo puede tener un gobierno reconocido]
Pues bien Pekín ha multiplicado su agenda
diplomática para acabar con esta situación.
Hoy, apenas un año después, ya son solo
18 países, casi todos minúsculos.
Pero eso no es todo. De hecho, dadas las circunstancias,
este movimiento de Pekín sería comprensible.
[Yo soy el gobierno legítimo de China]
Pero esto ya no es una cuestión sobre quién
es el gobierno legítimo... sino que simplemente,
Pekín ha dicho por activa y por pasiva...
que nunca va a permitir la independencia de
Taiwan.
Y una forma de impedirlo... es, precisamente,
tratando de borrar todo rastro de la identidad
nacional de la isla en el mundo.
[¿Taiwan? ¿Qué es eso de Taiwan?¿Una marca
de coches?]
Fijaos, en esta línea, Pekín está bloqueando
la presencia de los representantes de Taiwán
- e incluso de sus periodistas - en todos
los órganos internacionales que puede...
cómo por ejemplo en la Organización Mundial
de la Salud.
Está multando a las empresas que venden productos
en China con la etiqueta “Made in Taiwan”.
Le ha pasado por ejemplo a la cadena japonesa
Muji.
Otro caso que conocemos es el de la cadena
de ropa GAP que ha tenido que disculparse
por vender en Norteamérica camisetas que
no incluían a Taiwan como parte de China.
Luego, Grupos de música taiwaneses, cómo
la banda de indie punk Fire ex, que no son
partidarios de la reunificación están desapareciendo
de los servicios chinos de música en streaming
.
Y.... ¿Queréis un último ejemplo?
Pues... Ante la amenaza de Pekín las compañías
aéreas, de todo el mundo, están dejado de
utilizar el nombre de la isla.
Sí, tal cual como lo escucháis.
Ni siquiera las compañías estadounidenses
utilizan ya el nombre de Taiwan.
Es decir, sí, podeis reservar un billete
a Taipei desde Nueva York... pero simplemente
no preguntéis a qué país vais.
(Eso sí, a diferencia de otras compañías
internacionales como British Airways o Lufthansa,
que ya sitúan a la hora de vender los billetes
a Taiwan como parte de China... las compañías
estadounidenses han recurrido simplemente
al truco del país fantasma... vendo billetes
a Taipei... pero ¿qué donde esta eso? A
quién le importa?)
Claro que no podemos culparlas... el mercado
de la aviación chino es demasiado grande....
y además muchas compañías tienen intereses
directos en el país.
Sin ir más lejos... American Airlines es
accionista de China Southern Airlines y Delta,
por su parte, lo es de China Eastern Airline.
(“La meta de China respecto a Taiwán nunca
ha cambiado. Su objetivo es acabar con la
soberanía de Taiwán, exterminar la democracia
taiwanesa y lograr la unificación definitiva”.
Lee Teng-hui, primer presidente elegido democráticamente
de Taiwán.)
Sin embargo... esperad un momento... porque
no todos son malas noticias para Taiwán.
Junto al apoyo de los Estados Unidos, a la
isla le ha surgido otro poderoso aliado...
O... mejor dicho... Taiwán está desarrollando
su propia pócima mágica...
Y no, no estoy hablamos de armas. Atentos.
(LA MECA DE LA LIBERTAD)
Amigos, Taiwan ha sido elegida como el primer
anfitrión asiático del Foro de la Libertad
de Oslo, algo así como un Congreso, un encuentro
internacional sobre derechos humanos.
Pero... claro... puede que alguno de vosotros
se esté preguntando... ¿Un Congreso? ¿Es
eso realmente tan importante?
Pues lo cierto amigos es que sí. NO tanto
por el Congreso, sino sobre todo por lo que
significa.
(“Aunque la democracia mundial ha experimentado
una tendencia general de retroceso en los
últimos años, la democracia de Taiwaán
ha persistido y sigue prosperando.
Taiwan puede continuar sirviendo de inspiración
a los demócratas de Asia, incluidos los de
China”. Ketty Chen, Vicepresidente de la
Fundación para la Democracia de Taiwan.)
Veréis, durante décadas, Hong Kong fue el
gran bastión de la libertad de expresión
en esta zona del mundo.
(Tanto los medios de comunicación internacionales,
como las organizaciones de derechos humanos
establecieron allí sus sedes.
Y no solo eso, Hong Kong también se convirtió
en todo un refugio para muchos exiliados políticos
... como por ejemplo, los líderes estudiantiles
que lideraron las protestas de Tiananmen.)
Sin embargo, en los últimos tiempos y como
ya hemos visto aquí en VisualPolitik... las
cosas están cambiado... Y Pekín ha endurecido
su control sobre la política hongkonesa.
(“Hong Kong fue originalmente la primera
opción para la oficina de Asia, pero hoy
China no solo reprime a su propio pueblo,
ahora está exportando cada vez más esa represión
a Hong Kong. Wu´er Kaixi, disidente chino
y miembro de Reporteros Sin Fronteras )
Pero... al mismo tiempo que se producía este
cambio... Taiwán se ha consolidado como una
democracia vibrante y uno de los lugares más
libres de toda la región.
Precisamente por eso está sustituyendo a
Hong Kong como la Meca para los activistas
por la libertad y los derechos humanos en
Asia.
[Y eso que hasta 1987, Taiwan estuvo bajo
el control de una férrea dictadura]
Ahora, por ejemplo, uno de los festivales
de cine sobre derechos humanos que se celebraba
en Hong Kong se ha traslado a Taiwan;
Lam Wing-Kee uno de los editores de libros
de Hong Kong que fue secuestrado por agentes
del gobierno chino hace 2 años, ha anunciado
que re-abrirá su librería en Taiwán.
Y Reporteros sin Fronteras anunció en 2017
que su primera oficina asiática estará en
Taipei.
(“La libertad de expresión es muy importante
en la cultura taiwanesa". Cedric Alviani,
Director de la Oficina de Reporteros Sin Fronteras
en Taipeí.)
Amigos… Estos son solo algunos ejemplos
de lo que ya es una tendencia generalizada.
Democracia, pluralidad política, libertad
de expresión, derechos humanos, matrimonio
homosexual... Taiwán se está convirtiendo
en toda una referencia.
Y evidentemente esto plantea un problema enorme
para los intereses chinos.
(Por un lado los taiwaneses están encantados
con la libertad... así que, por supuesto,
no quieren saber absolutamente nada de volver
a estar bajo las órdenes de Pekín.
Por otro lado, mientras el gobierno chino
trata de borrar, de aniquilar la identidad
de Taiwán en el mundo... el país emerge
de repente como un centro de libertad... con
toda la influencia que ello conlleva. )
Además, es mucho más difícil plantearse
agredir a un país que sea conocido, precisamente,
por su apuesta por los derechos humanos. La
Comunidad Internacional no podría aceptarlo.
Y amigos, esta puede ser la mejor jugada de
Taiwán. Atentos.
(LA NUEVA JUGADA)
A mediados del pasado mes de julio de 2018,
entró en servicio el segundo escuadrón de
helicópteros apache, made in Taiwan.
Forma parte de lo que está siendo un fortalecimiento
en la alianza entre Washington y Taipei [De
lo que, por cierto, hablaremos en un próximo
vídeo], que entre otras cosas contempla un
importante incremento en la venta de equipos
y tecnología militar a la isla.
(Taiwan estás comprando helicópteros, tanques,
misiles, sistemas antiaéreos y ahora incluso
quiere desarrollar sus propios submarinos.
Sin embargo... a pesar de todo ello, cada
vez parece más claro que tan solo militarmente
Taiwan va a tener muy difícil frenar a China...
la diferencia de presupuestos es bestial...
El gasto militar de China es entre 15 y 20
veces el de Taiwan... y eso a la larga se
nota.)
Sí, es verdad, hoy por hoy está el paragua
de los Estados Unidos... pero incluso con
eso no basta.
Para tener la garantía de que la comunidad
internacional actuaría en su favor, Taiwan
necesita reforzar su influencia en el mundo....
sobre todo si aspira a convertirse a todas
luces en un país independiente.
Ahora bien, la pregunta que podemos hacernos
es ¿Cómo diantres lograrlo?
Pues, amigos, aunque nos pueda sorprender,
la estrategia militar - siendo imprescindible
- tal vez no sea la más importante.
Taiwán tiene que ganar influencia y protagonismo
en el mundo al tiempo que tiene que lograr
superar los problemas económicos de los que
ya os hablamos en un anterior vídeo.
Para ello, puede por ejemplo, buscar atraer
a estudiantes de toda Asia y de todo el mundo...dándoles
facilidades, impulsando los programas en inglés
y atrayendo profesores de primer nivel. Eso
supondría ganar mucha influencia y, claro,
capital humano, también.
Segundo, Taiwan puede poner en marcha una
política agresiva para atraer multinacionales
y lograr que establezcan aquí no solo fábricas
sino sobre todo centros de investigación
y sedes administrativas.
Ojo, dedicándole especial atención a la
atracción de empresas de creación de contenidos:
medios de comunicación, estudios de cine,
youtubers ¿por qué no?, etcétera, etcétera.
Tercero... el gobierno podría buscar convertirse
en todo un enclave logístico... por ejemplo
desarrollando sus capacidades aeroportuarias
y convirtiéndose así en un gran hub de comunicaciones.
Cuarto, puede atraer más profesionales del
resto de Asia... Lo que le permitiría por
un lado enfrentarse al envejecimiento de la
población de la isla y por otro lado reforzar
sus lazos con los lugares de origen de estos
trabajadores.
Y quinto tiene que continuar impulsado su
papel como centro de los derechos humanos
y la libertad de expresión.
(Tal vez un plan de estas características
no sea tan excitante como enormes planes de
armas... pero resultaría mucho más económico
[tratar de competir con China solo con la
vía militar se antoja complicado], impulsaría
la economía de la isla y le daría muchísima
influencia en todo el mundo.
Dadas las circunstancias, una universidad,
un estudio de cine, un hotel o la sede de
una organización de derechos humanos u multinacional
puede ser mucho más importante para la supervivencia
de la isla que, por ejemplo, un barco de guerra.
Y no, no se trata de tener un discurso ultrapacifista
ni nada por el estilo… se trata de puro
pragmatismo…)
Pero para terminar, amigos, me vais a permitir
hacer una reflexión.
Veréis, los países democráticos tal vez
cometieron una grave error cuando permitieron
que Hong Kong terminará no solo volviendo
a formar parte de China sino sobre todo que
volviera a estar bajo el control político
de Pekín.
Los que nos veis habitualmente sabéis que
en VisualPolitik le otorgamos un gran protagonismo
a China y que no solo no somos pesimistas
sino que reconocemos muchas contribuciones
positivas que están teniendo su origen en
el gigante asiático… Ahí está por ejemplo,
el despegue de África.
Sin embargo, amigos, el papel de China con
Taiwán es muy diferente y me pregunto, ¿Realmente
queremos repetir el mismo error que con Hong
Kong?
Pero ahora turno para tí ¿Crees que la Comunidad
Internacional debe garantizar la seguridad
de Taiwán?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo dale
a like y no olvides suscribirte a Visualpolitik
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.